we have
many
famous unfortunately no longer living in
many cases
uh scientists who were early users of
mathematica whose whose actual sort of
handwritten registration cards still
exist
but uh i was just looking
i was curious about i don't know
something and i was looking at the the
current batch of registrations guys just
come in sometime in 1989
and um
i just been been looking at this was a
time when roger penrose had just
published a um
a book called something like emperor's
new mind or some such other thing which
was um and there was a summary of the
book
in time magazine
that then the summary was something like
uh
you know computers are all dummies it
says says roger penrose or some such
other that's a paraphrase um
and so i just been looking at this and
literally then i'm leafing through these
registration cards and there's a card
from roger penrose and it's like like i
was just really amused that um uh the
juxtaposition of the um of the computers
are all dummies
report of his book and the well okay
they're not such dummies because this is
a useful thing mathematica that uh that
that can be used there i would say in
the in the um in the kind of famous
users of things department uh one thing
we've been trying to track down it's
about to be the 20th anniversary next
year of uh my big book a new kind of
science
and um in sort of as one of the the
elements of that anniversary we have
been
trying to track down sort of famous
readers of that book
and one way to track that down is when
there are pictures of people and you can
see it on their bookshelf
it's a good it's an interesting sign now
the book happens to be for those who've
seen it it's a very thick book 1280
pages long
and
it has a very notable
black and yellow spine i'm sure there
are ones up here yes there's ones there
um the
um
it's uh
uh and so that that's something that you
can sort of readily see on somebody's
bookshelf and so we've been doing a
little bit of a hunt
uh on on sort of uh notable people's
bookshelves for can you see
uh an nks book there for example there's
a
spotted on bill gates's bookshelf
spotted on mark zuckerberg's desk
um
spotted on uh
an elon musk um desk
spotted on um various kinds of uh
different different people different
places um where nks books have shown up
but it's a particularly uh it's kind of
a
a problem not yet solved by image search
and ai to go you know search the web for
places where the book shows up as a
sub-piece of an image but but um uh in
any case that's kind of a an interesting
sort of um
um uh place to uh uh
to find out whether uh whether people
have have the book on their bookshelf so
if anybody knows of of uh notable
uh places where the nks book is visible
on a bookshelf or something uh let us
know because we're trying to make a
collection of these things it's actually
already a pretty big collection that we
have and i'm forgetting most of the most
of the
places there's some pretty interesting
ones the ones i mentioned just a few
that that come to mind
uh so don't don't really know the the
answer to the some most famous
mathematical uses it also depends on
what you mean by most famous
um
let's see we have another question here
from alex
what separates the greats
by which he or she means uh einstein
dirac newton etc from everyone else
is there a tip that i might have for a
young physics undergraduate to come
become a better physicist
you
know a couple of comments here i mean
the
it is
usually the case that fields go through
and i've said this many times fields go
through these these sudden moments of
rapid expansion and growth
followed by
50 years 100 years of sort of
fairly slow growth and typically what
initiates one of those bursts of rapid
growth is some methodological advance of
some kind
or some new way of looking at or
thinking about that kind of field some
kind of paradigm shifty type thing
that's happened and so what you'll
typically see is a bunch of sort of
notable discoveries clustered around the
time when that methodological advance is
possible
and in my own life i've been fortunate
enough to kind of be involved in a few
things that i i think
have already turned out to be fairly
important and which i think will end up
being
vastly more important actually in the
future
and in a sense
the you know
what i would say is that the main thing
that's caused it to be possible to make
those discoveries
is simply that i've lived at the right
time in history
and so for example back in the early
1980s when i was discovering things by
doing
computer experiments on simple programs
and so on
that was something that was readily
doable in the 1980s because computer
technology had reached the point where
that was possible
and it would not have been readily
doable if i you know shift me back a few
decades that wouldn't have been readily
possible
at some point
probably those experiments get done and
so if you live
sort of today
those most basic experiments have
already been done so it's kind of a one
thing is at what time in history do you
live now of course
there's a certain freedom because
you know you know what time in history
you're living at and the question is
what's the thing that is just now
becoming methodologically possible at
that time in history and of course the
other part of that story is is that
something for which you have some
particular talent or skill or insight
that you can
bring together with the methodological
advance that exists in the world to
produce something that is sort of an
exciting uh push forward now if you look
at
i think
well let's take dirac for example 1930s
involved in kind of the
mathematicization of quantum mechanics
in a sense what happened there was dirac
was a very mathematical thinking kind of
person
who
was kind of
uh brought himself into this area
quantum mechanics that was this kind of
new
thing where in a sense it was both
induced by some experiments but also
the result of kind of the um
uh
the sort of the the
addition of of
somewhat fancy mathematics to physics
in a sense the the development of
physics for a long time it had been like
well newton kind of introduced the idea
of let's use calculus to do physics and
that kind of developed uh through the
1700s and 1800s laplace and then
eventually maxwell people like that into
you know it's a big differential
equations festival so to speak as
quantum mechanics came on the scene
there were things like matrices which
were an exotic mathematical concept at
the time and things about oh i don't
know uh all sorts of hilbert spaces all
sorts of mathematicization
that was sort of wheeling in advanced
mathematics that hadn't been present in
physics dirac was aware of that advanced
mathematics and was able to combine it
with this kind of uh interest in quantum
mechanics that have developed at that
time and so he was kind of on the
leading edge of the mathematicization of
quantum mechanics and was able to make
big contributions there i mean for
example the appearance of quantum
mechanics at the time it did i was
thinking about this recently and trying
to understand what was the what was the
kind of thing that caused quantum
mechanics to arise
1900 1905 to 1920s i mean basically the
history is you know max planck around
1900
realized that
he kind of did this fit to the black
body spectrum the the
spectrum of electromagnetic radiation
produced by just a hot object of a
certain temperature
um the
and realized that oh you could get a
better fit if you assumed that photons
didn't obey the statistics that people
thought ordinary molecules and things
obeyed but obeyed a different kind of
statistics and that was the the planck
distribution uh
eventually bose einstein uh
um distribution function
um
that was he kind of realized as the sort
of numerical fit to data that it could
be explained if there was discreteness
in photons and einstein came along in
1905 and noticed that the photoelectric
effect could be explained by the idea of
sort of particle-like photons and so on
and then in the 1920s
there was kind of uh
somewhat driven by things like the the
study of spectral lines and so on the
the um uh was kind of the introduction
by schrodinger of the
um his wave equation heisenberg's matrix
mechanics things like that
those were the the theoretical things
but there was an important i think
experimental thing that happened which
was i think that quantum mechanics was
the result of the of the invention of
amplifiers
see in the past
for example
a lot of development in biology from the
1600s on was the result of microscopes
the existence of microscopes and you
could see what were those organelles
inside a cell
uh the development of astronomy
obviously uh in the beginning of the
1600s the discovery of the telescope
invention of the telescope
and uh used by galileo in 1608 to find
the moons of jupiter that was kind of a
key moment in the history of astronomy
so again it's kind of the the telescope
the microscope were things which allowed
one to see
things that hadn't been seeable before
and led to advances in fields of biology
and um uh
and astronomy and and therefore physics
and so on so the question is what else
could you not see before that you
started being able to see and the answer
i think is just small effects
small electrical effects for example how
do you amplify a small electrical effect
well what had happened was that right at
the beginning of the 1900s there were
was the development of uh well things
like radio
and the um and the fact that there were
amplifiers there were sort of feedback
circuits that could progressively
amplify a signal and i'm pretty sure
that's what was important in the
development of quantum mechanics it was
also the kind of the idea of things like
geiger counters for measuring
radioactivity they were again these
things that had sort of this notion of
amplification of a small signal and i
think that's that's sort of the
essential thing that initiated the the
um uh the kind of uh the the uh a lot of
what was done in quantum mechanics
so
if you look at different kinds of people
like einstein
what was his kind of um
uh secret source in a sense
i think you kind of get some sense of
that from looking at his paper on
special relativity in 1905.
it has essentially no references maybe
even actually no references it's very
short paper
and what it does is it argues
by thought experiments it argues about
things like you know if you were to
uh have this sort of flash of light here
and you were to do this and try and
synchronize things and so on it doesn't
do something where it says write down an
equation and then figure out the answer
it's much more of a kind of
it goes back to a much earlier tradition
in a sense of doing natural philosophy
rather than doing sort of mathematically
built science
and i think what einstein particularly
brought to things was this kind of idea
of let's just figure stuff out by sort
of logical thinking rather than let's
try to um to sort of have a a thing that
is oh we've got the structure now let's
build another uh story on this tower
that we're building
so
and you know einstein was a
very
uh capable technically capable person
who um
uh
also sort of learnt the mathematics he
needed to learn
in in developing general relativity in
1915 he particularly needed to learn
about tensor calculus
which was a a pretty new thing at the
time and he always would say you know
it's it's kind of at the limit of the
mathematics that i know you know he
wrote that in many letters and said that
to many people and i think that was you
know he had this sort of the the the
logical thinking and the physical
intuition to know this is what's needed
and uh um but the actual technical stuff
he was certainly capable of of learning
it but that wasn't something that that
was the where it came from so to speak
um i think
so
in terms of you know how to
i think the the thing that is always
great to kind of identify is where are
places where there is sort of a new
methodological direction
that's the place where you're going to
be able to make great contributions the
the it is much easier to make great
contributions at a time when there's
sort of rapid growth in a field than at
a time where
it's a different situation when a field
is in sort of its cruise phase um when
the the methodology is sort of
understood for the field and it's just a
question of of sort of drilling further
building further um that that
that's a different type of of
contribution that can be made
i i would say that one of the things
that for me has been interesting in our
physics project recently is we kind of
hit
a remarkable kind of seam of of a sort
of uh
very productive uh you know if we're
thinking about a mining analogy we've
kind of uh um hit pay dirt or something
in um uh
and i'm not sure that's quite the right
terminology for mining but you know
we've hit this very rich seam
uh of of ideas
that i have to say i wasn't i didn't
know were there
and
but this is something that has emerged
from this kind of tower of ideas that um
uh that i've developed over the course
of decades now um but now that there are
that we've hit this kind of seam of
ideas that revolve around kind of the
the structure of our physics project
this idea of multi-computation
uh multi-way systems all sorts of things
about hypergraphs and so on this is just
a tremendously fertile kind of thing
and you know in in in the future people
will say oh yeah this was you know
uh lots of great things were discovered
around this
um
and in a sense it's just it it you know
this got opened up and now it's rather
easy to discover great things or it will
be for a little while maybe five years
maybe 10 i don't know um so that's an
example of of sort of a place where
where there's so discovery is in the air
so to speak and that tends to be the
places where there's a lot of clustering
of of sort of uh great things in let's
say physics or something around those
kinds of places now it has to be said
that like with many kinds of
opportunities
it's not the case that you can typically
kind of walk into something like that
and immediately solve these problems
there's usually some tower that's been
built in that area some technical thing
that you have to understand to be able
to get to the place where you can
actually make contributions
but it's some in these areas that have
just been opened up often the technical
towers are well there's there's good
news and bad news the good news is the
technical tower is not as tall because
it just hasn't had as long to be built
the bad news is it's harder to learn it
often because there aren't sort of the
well-developed textbooks and courses and
you know and exercises and so on to do
because it's new and that just hasn't
developed yet
so
i would say that the um uh the one thing
that is clear in these times is you know
i have to give a pitch for
learn computational language you know
learn the kind of tools that we've built
over these years
as a way to discover things in science
if you are fluent in wolfram language
mathematica whatever um you know there
are just things you can immediately do
that have been completely out of out of
reach and that's kind of the you know a
new thing of our times of the last few
decades of the existence of that
technology just makes it enables a lot
of things in science and physics that
were just not possible before along with
another thing that enables new things as
kind of ideas and that's a lot of what's
come out that's enabled our physics
project now is ideas about computation
that partly come from experience with
actually doing computation and
understanding the tools for doing that
and partly come from
from pure theoretical thinking
but i would say that that
you're asking what what sort of
separates the the great science crowd
from the
the the um uh more sort of uh
just another scientist crowd type thing
i think it's often the the fact that
their great contributions were at these
cusps
where where big things were happening
usually because they brought in a new
paradigm a new kind of idea about how to
deal with things newton did that too
newton you know the the title of his
book principia was you know mathematical
principles of natural philosophy before
his time people had just tried to do the
thing that i was mentioning that
einstein came back and did later which
is kind of just reason about science
with philosophically rather than having
some kind of power tool to deal with it
in newton's time the power tool that he
had was mathematics
he kind of modeled his mathematics on
euclid and kind of this geometric
demonstration kind of thing although he
in fact invented the methodologies of
calculus
and uh he was able to use that to that
sort of power tool to build much taller
tower in physics than had been built
before in today's time
that the corresponding tool is
computation
and that's that's the thing that allows
one just as newton was able to go in and
kind of get further with with physics
than people had got because he had this
new set of tools that were mathematical
tools some of his own invention some
that already existed
so now today
computation is that corresponding sort
of new tool that exists and i would say
that computation has not been for
example in physics
has been applied not terribly much i
mean it's it's uh people certainly use
mathematica and things to do physics but
they've done physics the way physics was
done before with equations and all that
kind of thing the notion of using
computation as a core idea to do physics
to actually create the structure of
physics well that's kind of the story of
our physics project and that's in a
sense a new story it's a story that is
enabled by all the things that we know
about computation but that's a place
where one can expect sort of big new
things to happen so i think the um
uh the the typical thing is there's a
new methodology you learn a new
methodology you start applying it to
things even to problems where people
have said we've been wondering about
this problem for 200 years
and no progress was made well people
were bashing it with the existing
methodologies you have some new
methodology you can come in and
sometimes you can just leak to the top
of it and and and solve it with that new
methodology in fact i'm just in the
process of working on a bunch of things
about metamathematics and the
foundations of mathematics that i've
thought about for i don't know 40 years
or so and uh they were last really
worked on big time about
110 120 years ago
um
and i think we can now see using modern
methods that we have and modern ideas
that we have we can kind of jump
very far forward on that on problems
that have been very mysterious for a
long time
and the fact that that's possible as a
result of both well one of the things
that i suppose in in my particular
methodology for doing things i sort of
realized this recently
is um
kind of an interesting methodology
which is that there's sort of two
branches of the methodology one is kind
of general
sort of logical philosophical
structural thinking
of kind of how should things work let's
reason about them and developing decent
intuition for how things might work and
kind of it's all in a sense just words
and just things that i might talk about
um in a forum like this that's branch
number one of methodology branch number
two is computer experiments and things
like language design and sort of making
computational the things that i'm
talking about
and that's a very different kind of
methodology it's a methodology which
like the first one forces one to have a
clear understanding what one's talking
about because one doesn't understand
what one's talking about one doesn't
have a hope of being able to explain it
to a computer
but but actually doing
those computer experiments and so on
that's a very different kind of thing
than the kind of just thinking about
things type of type of activity and so
it's something that you're very down
grounded when you're doing um
those kinds of computer experiments you
know you do the experiment it does what
it does uh you you you're like a natural
scientist you're seeing what did my
computer just do can i understand what
my computer just did which is a very
different kind of activity than the kind
of let me just imagine something
conceptually type of activity and so
it's sort of strange because in a sense
in the things i do they're those two
extreme cases a lot of what people do in
science is somewhere in the middle they
don't think very strategically and sort
of almost philosophically about the
structure of what's going on and they
don't do the practical computer
experiments they're sort of somewhere in
the middle working with some level of
formalism and so on and i i think the
methodology that i've ended up kind of
falling into using is a pretty
productive one but it's a slightly
unusual one and insofar as i've been
able to discover things that that hadn't
been discovered before part of it has to
do with the fact that the methodology is
somewhat different
so i think that's uh
that's some
uh
i would say
how to become a better physicist
learn computational language tools
that's a that's a very concrete way to
do it that's one thing the other thing
is
given any question
ask you know what what is the real
question you know you you're asked about
and also don't assume
that
some sort of slick explanation that
you don't understand is the actual story
like one of my favorites is friction
so you may know that you know people
talk about friction down at i don't know
high school level least physics
and uh
you know one of the features of friction
is that the frictional force is
proportional to the normal force it's
proportional how hard you push the
object down the amount of frictional
force increases linearly with normal
force that's the usual formula and
there's a coefficient of friction the
question is what is fr what causes
friction
and why is that law
anton
what is that law called it doesn't
usually have a however it has it's named
after somebody from a very long time ago
from at least the 1600s
um the uh
you know why does it work that way well
the answer is people don't really know
completely you know it's like well the
surfaces have these kind of sort of
rough surfaces on the area of contact
increases as you push it down harder and
so on but it's not completely clear why
it should be linear maybe that's the
first order effect and there's higher
order ones but that's an example of
something where you might just say you
know textbook might just say f equals mu
times n that's the story that's the end
of it
well you can actually think about those
things now sometimes there will be a
well understood derivation that exists
and sometimes there won't be sometimes
like for example in physics of i don't
know physics of sand that was the thing
that got popular maybe 25 years ago and
i sort of wondered about it and i kind
of uh like how does sand work it's not
kind of like a fluid like water where
you have sort of very tiny molecules you
can actually see the grains of sand and
they they rub against each other and etc
etc etc and of course that turned into a
whole area of physics of granular
materials and all those kinds of things
and just sort of it's like well it's an
obvious question to ask but it turns out
people hadn't really asked it very much
now could it have been addressed with
methodologies that existed 100 years
earlier probably um i think it just was
a question that hadn't particularly been
asked and so i think the part of the
story is you know just ask the questions
even if they seem obvious there are
plenty of physical phenomena that are
sort of quite everyday that people have
not analyzed that well and that might be
accessible to tools that exist today i
mean i would also say that it's a
general principle that um the more
deeply you understand stuff
the more you can really answer the sort
of strategic questions about things
rather than just work out the formulas
so to speak the better chance you will
have to be able to make a sort of
foundational advance because if you're
just sort of operating at the level of
the formulas kind of thing it's like
well you'll only be able to to swim at
that level if you actually understand
what's down at the bedrock you can build
kind of a different tower there
oh boy we've got many many questions
here um
let's see
um
there's a question here from georgios
asking about saying the physicist
didn't learn in discrete mathematics
um got involved with our summer school
but didn't have enough technical
knowledge to get the most out of it
what advice do i have i think
just try doing little experiments
just the best way you know discrete
mathematics for example
it's like
it's something where much even much more
so than continuous mathematics you can
just try the experiment you know
work out i don't know let's say good a
random example if you take random
mappings if you just take a bunch of
integers and you say i'm randomly going
to pair integers up with each other and
you ask you know what kind of a graph do
i get when i pair up integers randomly
well you'll find if you try and work out
um what's the uh you know how connected
is that graph those kinds of things just
do the experiments look at them trivial
to do the experiments um in um
at least a more language that's trivial
and then say why does it work that way
and start trying to sort of back learn
the mathematics again how one learns
things is a somewhat personal thing and
for me
i always find it best to have a a
project even if it's a fairly small one
and then try and kind of explore from
the project so to speak what things i
need to know what foundations i need to
know
to to uh be able to to do things with
that project now our full physics
project is pretty complicated and it's
probably not the place to start i would
start by looking at cellular automata
turing machines trying to look at the
discrete mathematics of those those are
much
structurally simpler the whole
hypergraph rewriting multi-way system
thing it's just very it it has it's very
non-human um i mean sorry that's just
the way the universe happens to work it
seems um you know it it uh it's just not
something we humans are particularly
able to grasp quickly things like
cellular automata are a lot easier and
that's probably a good place to start is
with experiments on those and so on
let's see
uh
there's a question
um
oh so many interesting questions here
all right one from attori
uh when you look at the history of of
technology how far back should you go
so it says um uh tried to study the
story of machine learning and in some
sense the first decision tree was 500 bc
and even earlier in the bible
yeah well
you know it's always an interesting
question when did people really cotton
on to some idea
when
most
ideas have precursors
most
and
but sometimes those precursors can only
be identified once you have really got
the idea really wrapped your arms around
the idea
then you can go back and say
oh these people almost got the idea
an example
where
uh universal computation
thing that arose in the 1930s precursors
of the 1920s
pseudo precursors in the 1830s
um you know when did that idea really
arise you know you can start saying well
they're these comments that are made by
you know
i don't know
saint augustine or something let's say i
don't know specific ones there which
kind of sound like uh universal
computation
but
see one of the tricky things is when you
go back
to
a time when the
description methodology was different
ideas look different so for example
after the 1600s
after science gets mathematicized
many ideas in many areas of science not
all areas of science get stated
mathematically and you can kind of say
oh
there's the equation f equals m a or
something
we can see there's that equation and
that equation uh you know has an origin
at this time and it can then moves
forward
but if you say
that there was a description of
something that might have been force
equals mass times acceleration but it
was represented as like say kepler did
it as you know some kind of musical
score or it was represented as some kind
of allegory that was told in words and
some story was it really f equals a or
was it something different by the time
you have a particular description
methodology you can often say that was
the origin point because you can kind of
see it looks the same as it does today
by the way i would say that looking
forwards you know this is the time where
the idea of computation and
computational language is becoming the
description language for lots of events
lots of things that are discovered and
people will say well was there a
precursor of such and such a thing
because we can see what it's like in
these computational terms now can we go
back and see what it was like before now
for example i was interested in doing
that for my new kind of science book
trying to study sort of the distant
history of things and for example i was
interested in how were things built
according to rules
because in a sense running a computer
program is like following a certain set
of rules and so the question was what
existed in the past that was like
following since systematically following
rules
so for example um cellular automata you
know these uh arrays of black and white
squares they look a bit like mosaic
where did mosaic originate well it
originated in babylon
it was there's a famous um uh piece of
mosaic that has some some stripey pieces
and some other pieces uh it was some
i think it's even said that it was made
by gilgamesh although it's not even
completely clear gilgamesh was a
historical person famous for his epic of
gilgamesh so to speak um but uh uh you
know that was a place where yes the
mosaic was sort of made by rules was it
like a program well not really it was
just a you know a piece of mosaic then i
was looking at other kinds of places
where there were systems of rules like
for example you know when you arranged a
you know in the roman army or something
when you were arranging one of those you
know tortoise configurations or
something that's like lots of people
arranging themselves in a particular way
is that kind of like the rules type
construction type thing uh you know
where can you go back given that you now
have this idea of programs can you
project backwards and kind of see that
idea kind of uh
beginning to
to stick its head out so to speak um
even thousands of years earlier and it's
it's often you know if if you went back
and started one sort of thought
experiment test is you go back and you
talk to
mr gilgamesh when he was making his
mosaic and you start explaining programs
would would he understand or would he
just be completely confused and it's
like i don't know what earth you're
talking about
i think that's sort of a a conceivable
test
um for whether whether the idea really
existed at that time or whether it
needed a whole a whole collection of
intermediate kind of structure before
the idea could really exist
so you mentioned things like decision
trees and machine learning
you know i'm quite certain that there
are
descriptions of
what amount to decision trees you know
if you could do this or you could do
that and if this happens then that
happens i'm i'm quite sure there are
prescriptions in in the bible and other
places that contain things which are if
then if then if then
type branching kind of uh
cases and yes i i think that's you know
you can think of that as the origin of a
decision tree if you ask the question uh
if you start asking um
i mean it depends at some level that
that's one which i think is as easily
described in words if you start saying
you know are you learning the decision
tree from data
well you know you might say well people
got used to having this decision tree
because they were experienced at doing a
lot of things but it's a little
different than the sort of systematic
approach of modern machine learning of
you know systematically tweaking the
weights to achieve a particular
configuration
but but i think it's always an
interesting question when uh you know
you end up with these things and it
comes up also like should so and so get
the credit for idea x
and
it's like you know well they almost had
idea x
and if you kind of squint at it in the
right way you can kind of see it as idea
x but it's very hard to tell in many
cases
um i would i would say that um
even in my own life in looking at things
i've done
in the past and it's like did i have the
idea of xyz i'll give you an example
so
uh these multi-way systems that are a
big piece of what we're doing in the
physics project
when did that idea originate well i mean
there are precursors to that idea but
the idea is in very much its modern form
in my new kind of science book
um i you know i have a section called
multi-way systems and i've got all these
pictures of these things that are what
we now call multi-wave systems
now uh i can talk about the precursors
of that
i've tried to study the precursors the
precursors were well let me let me
explain a little bit so in a multi-wave
system the idea is you have a state like
let's say it's a string of characters
and you have a rule and the rule says
from one state you can generate
potentially many states
and the multi-way system you have this
whole graph of from this state you
produce these states and often from a
single state you can have a branch where
you produce multiple states you can also
have a merge where the states that are
produced turn out to be the same and so
you merge them in this graph
okay so that's kind of the idea of a
multi-way system and the question is one
question is what were the sort of
precursors of that
well this idea that there are many
possible branches on which you can go
that's an idea that originated when
people talked about non-deterministic
uh well first finite automata in the
1950s then fight non-deterministic
touring machines around 1970 um that's
but but they didn't quite have the same
idea because they had this idea of all
kinds of branching but they really said
but we want to get one answer there is
one path that is the one we're trying to
pick out there are lots of paths but
what we really want is just that one
path that is going to be the winning
path
so
in when i was looking at multi-wave
systems in the 1990s i was looking at
them as kind of a
a just another kind of computational
system i didn't really think of them as
particularly significant i knew that
they corresponded you could think of
them as paths through them as being like
mathematical proofs and things like this
or part through them being like chemical
synthesis pathways those kinds of things
and i thought they were an interesting
idealization of those kinds of systems
but that was kind of as far as i got
with them
recently with the physics project this
was actually uh partly initiated by an
idea of jonathan gorod's about quantum
mechanics
that um uh this idea that the multi-way
system is sort of a representation of
the whole of reality and that in a sense
we
as as observers of the system aren't
just looking at the one winning path
we're actually looking at a whole
cluster of paths we're looking at this
whole kind of let's take us too too far
afield into the physics project to talk
about this in great detail but much like
we're kind of when we study i don't know
molecules in a gas we're not looking at
every individual molecule we're just
looking at the overall effect of lots of
molecules that determine kind of the
fluid structure of the gas so similarly
in this multi-way systems we're not
looking at a single history we're
looking at a whole clump of histories
that that we all sort of consider
together so to speak
and so that idea of multi-way systems
where you're not just looking at one
winning path but you're looking at this
whole branchial space as we now call it
of many different paths that's an idea
that's now two years old and you know
you can perhaps find vague precursors of
that idea
but that idea is kind of a it's still
talking about multi-way systems it's
still talking about things that look a
bit like non-deterministic computation
but from a different vantage point and
with a different emphasis of what's
important
so that's a case where you know even in
i would say you know did i did i invent
that set of ideas back in the 1990s well
not really because i wasn't really
emphasizing that now in fact some
technical things that i did
depended on that exactly those kinds of
ideas but it didn't really internalize
the sort of full significance of this
notion of things like branch hill space
and so on back at that time so in a
sense if you say did i have that idea
well you can find things where i'm sort
of doing things that sort of poke at
that idea but i would say at least
internally that i didn't have that idea
at that time the kind of the full
conceptualization of that didn't come
until very recently
so you know this is a kind of thing
where you can say did so and so have the
idea well yes they've got little you
know little sort of uh little points
where they're they're sort of pieces of
the idea and you can see the idea poking
through now the question is in their
internal state did they really have the
idea but they just weren't emphasizing
it or it wasn't sort of the big front
and center idea they were just
seeing little pokes of the idea and so
on i you know it's very hard to tell
that uh you could tell a little bit by
talking to the person but uh if they're
no longer around you don't get that
opportunity and you can sometimes read
their writings it's like did they have
this idea did they not have this idea
it's really hard to tell i mean i could
say with some people who worked on
things that uh are related to the
physics project there are some people i
don't know one person who i i might give
a little shout out to his personal david
finkelstein who i met a number of times
who was a very interesting talented
and creative physicist
who wrote a bunch of books
that might be to do might relate to our
physics project or might not it's really
hard to tell and i think one thing that
that
um
you know he even told me at one time he
said you know yes my works are slightly
confusing because sometimes i will you
know i'll just if i think something
wasn't right before i'll just write a
new document but i won't even mention
the older document that i now think is
wrong so there's sort of multiple
archaeological levels in that case and
that's yet another sort of thing that
compounds the difficulty of finding was
there something there or not
um and and if there was you know to me
you know what's the value of knowing
those kind of precursors i find it very
interesting that's why i'm doing
something like this q a about about
history of science and technology i find
it interesting because it helps me
contextualize
things i'm thinking about now to kind of
see how the paths of thinking about
things developed in the past for example
what was obvious at the time and what
was very hard to understand you know a
flow chart for example is something
which is related to the decision tree
thing that you mentioned is something
flow charts seem to be pretty natural
things that people invent and reinvent
and and so on whereas that's a natural
thing i don't know
[Music]
you know what what what things are
natural to invent what things are not
is uh sometimes there are things that
become natural to invent because of kind
of ambient
uh things in the world even though they
were not natural to invent when they
were first invented and some things once
you're thinking about those kinds of
questions it's natural to invent that
idea
okay
the um
there's a question here
uh from
uh well there's one question here from
zayden is excel a computational tool
boy i've never been a big excel user
actually excels has started uh in the
last few months making use of our
wolfram language technology you can now
find a sort of wolfram section of data
entities in excel and and i think
already some other uh microsoft office
products
so so maybe i i will uh they're sort of
starting to be pieces of our kind of
computational language ideas and and
computational knowledge ideas that are
poking through into excel i would say
that in general
excel has a bunch of interesting ideas
it's not really
it doesn't uh it's not the kind of
computational language approach that
that i've for example taken for the last
many decades although it has to be said
that in some ways excel is a kind of
functional programming language um in
certain in certain in certain fashions i
mean excel
it's interesting because
it's a very
okay so in different kinds of approaches
to programming there's different levels
of explicitness
in excel it's like you've got the
spreadsheet it's right there you know
what you're doing is just poking at that
spreadsheet
in a language like fortran let's say
it's like everything is hidden away in
variables there's no obvious state of
the system it's all like well i set x to
this and i have this array over here
called y and so on and it's all very
very hidden
i view our kind of computational
language approach of symbolic language
as sort of an intermediate thing because
a symbolic expression is much more
general much richer than what you can
get in just an array of of numbers and
so on but it's a numbers and strings and
such like but it's something which is
not the same kind of indirect hidden
state that you see in something like a
low-level programming language like
4chan or java or whatever else it's
something where you can pick up that
symbolic expression and you can see the
whole symbolic expression it's this tree
structured thing and it's got these
different pieces and you can kind of
read them and so on um it's it's kind of
the i think it's kind of the sweet spot
of the of being both
sort of something where you can pick it
up and understand it and something which
has kind of the full power of of what's
possible computationally but um so you
know i think um excel is kind of the
this special case of this sort of array
of of numbers um but it has the good
feature that yes you can explicitly see
what's going on and perhaps even more
easily than you can with the general
symbolic expression
uh question from rbs who invented poly
aminos why were they invented what role
did they play in mathematics
i actually know the answer to that it
was a they were invented by a person
called solomon golomb
who i knew uh fairly well for for
probably 40 years
he died um
five years ago now roughly
uh
so he
was some
uh
he invented polyaminos i think when he
was
a
graduate student at harvard
in mathematics
and i think he did it as a kind of
recreational
um
this was in the 1950s
he did it as kind of a um
a sort of a recreational game so
polyaminos are things where you have a
bunch of squares and their shapes like
if you played tetris it has sort of
polyamino like shapes in it they're just
a bunch of squares glued together so you
might have a polyamino that was a sort
of l-shaped bunch of squares glued
together or it might be another another
kind of but but the idea is it's bunches
of squares glued together and those are
the polyaminos generalization of
dominoes dominoes are like two squares
but the
the duo dominant doe
part of the domino word is like it's two
squares glued together a polyamino is
something where there are many squares
glued together and that word was
invented by sel galamb um in in the
1950s i think in his original in his
original uh like mathematics magazine
article about about the subject
he was interested
in questions like given a polyamino can
it tile the plane so for example we know
if you just have ordinary squares you
can obviously make a
you know a mosaic like pattern that just
covers a an infinite plane but if you
have l-shaped polyaminos it's much less
obvious you can do that maybe the two
l's can sort of fit together and make
rectangles and you can keep tiling from
those rectangles but so he was
interested in these questions about is
it possible to tile the plane with
certain kinds of shapes of polyominos
and so on
uh the polyaminos became
their many kind of puzzles and games and
so on that developed from polyamorous i
i wrote an obituary piece about seoul
golam and i i tried to find some of the
more exotic uses of polyaminos that had
been made but yeah they were invented as
kind of a sort of pseudo-recreational
math idea but then quickly turned into
this question about tiling now this
whole question about tiling is an
interesting one like everybody kind of
knows you can you can use squares to
tile the plane you can use hexagons to
tile the plane um kepler for example uh
discovered some other tilings there's a
so-called kepler tiling which is a
mixture of squares and octagons if you
just have a regular octagon you can't
tile the plane with the regular octagon
you can't tile the plane with a regular
pentagon either if you try and make if
you try and put a bunch of regular
pentagons together they'll curl
themselves up and maybe don't make a
dodecahedron if you make a bunch of
hexagons together they'll just make an
infinite plane
um in the case of um uh
so
this question of what can tile the plane
is one that's been interesting as i say
kepler did work on it it then became
something where people in the uh 1800s
studying the structure of crystal
lattices also were very interested in
this what kinds of crystals can you make
if you have a bunch of atoms that make
the unit cell of a particular
crystalline material what kinds of
arrangements can they be put in to still
tile in that particular case
three-dimensional space
but this question of sort of what
tilings are possible was one that became
of interest
and what happened let's see
um
there was a question
of whether it was decidable whether
whether something could tile the plane
what does that mean so you let's say you
have a bunch of you you've got this
you've got a puzzle and it's a bunch of
all identical pieces and you're asked is
there a way of arranging those identical
pieces so that you can make an infinite
puzzle maybe you know
cover an infinite plane with them now
what could happen is you could find this
set of pieces and you could say well i
can i can get it out to this size i can
make it a size you know a 10 by 10 blob
but now i'm stuck and i can't get go
further and the question is can you
prove that you can't go further you
might be a maybe you can make a size a
million blob but then you can't go
further and so the question is it
becomes like the halting problem for
touring machines this question of can
you
it's you might think it might be like
that can you determine just given the
puzzle pieces can you say yes these
puzzle pieces will be able to tile a
plane or no these puzzle pieces won't be
able to tile the plane and sometimes
it's completely obvious that they can't
tell the plane someone's completely
obvious they can but there's this zone
of intermediate cases where one wonders
could they tie look if they not tile so
i think it was around 1960
a person called burger
uh
uh
showed
that there was also a person called how
wang
uh who was involved in this
uh oh no i'm i'm i'm misremembering a
piece of this um there were several
people involved in this it was around
1960 this question of
was tiling decidable
that is would it be the case that for
any you could write a program basically
that would look at the tiles you got and
would be able to say
uh just run a little computation and say
yep it'll tile or no it won't tile
um
and um
what happened uh
i'm trying to remember the sequence here
i think this person burger was the first
person who showed that there existed a
set of tiles it might be a thousand
different tiles
um where you couldn't
where there was no way to know in
advance whether that particular set of
tiles of this type would would be able
to cover the infinite plane or not what
he did was he showed that if you imagine
a turing machine simple model of
computation we already know that the
halting problem for touring machines is
undecidable that is given the
specification of a turing machine if we
ask the question given a particular
initial configuration will the turing
machine just keep running always be in a
loop always be generating more
complicated stuff or will the turing
machine eventually reached some fixed
state that question is undecidable you
you could have to wait an arbitrary long
time in my way of thinking about these
things it's a computationally
irreducible problem there's no way you
can kind of jump ahead and say that
turing machine it just wasted its time
doing a trillion steps i could see the
answer in five steps
well that you can't do that is a
statement of computational
irreducibility and then when you ask
what the turing machine do after an
infinite time well that you won't be
able to answer with any finite
computation if there is computational
irreducibility but what berger showed
was that you could map this question
about tiling you could imagine you're
going to try and tell the plane you set
up a bunch of tiles as a line of tiles
and you say let me continue going down
the page and try and fill in more tiles
and what he showed was that that process
of filling in tiles was like the halting
problem for a non-deterministic turing
machine so it was what he showed is that
the the question of if if the thing
doesn't ever halt then that's a sign
that yes it successfully can tile the
plane if it does halt that means it got
stuck
and it doesn't tile the plane so then
people tried what he came up with was an
incredibly complicated set of tiles
uh a person called hao wang who was a
fairly well-known
uh early theoretical computer scientist
i think simplified that a bit a person
called raphael robinson who i
certainly met
um who had been kind of a number theory
person notable as the husband of julia
robinson julia robinson who i also met
um was a mathematician at um in berkeley
either both at berkeley
uh
and she was particularly notable
for having been a person who was got got
laid one of the important uh pieces of
groundwork for proving the unsolvability
of hilbert's tenth problem of proving
that that um there's undecidability in
equations involving integers if you ask
you know can there be integers such that
x cubed plus y to the fourth equals 17
z squared or something can you fill in
such integers that in general you can't
know the answer you can't prove that you
can't do that
in general with a finite proof you there
might be an integer that's incredibly
huge that would satisfy that and you
can't tell it's very similar to this
titling type problem so so julia
robinson um was uh
somebody who figured out a very clever
trick actually a number theory for which
almost managed to completely nail the
hilbert's tenth problem thing that was
eventually nailed by a person called
yuri matissewicz who i've known for many
years um it was uh at the time it was i
think 1968 that he finally solved that
it was one of these things where there
was a time when you know during the cold
war and sort of what was happening in
the soviet union was a bit separated
from what was happening elsewhere and it
was kind of this this sort of mysterious
moment when this young person had
suddenly solved the what's 10th problem
building on a bunch of work that julia
robinson and martin davis and other
people had done um on uh but julia
robinson invented a particularly nice
trick which almost got to the solution
to hebert's tenth problem anyway her
husband raphael robinson was interested
in slightly similar things and he
invented a much simpler set of of tiles
that would be
that whose general tiling question was
undecidable
um
the
uh
i have to say i've been on the hunt for
the very simplest set of tiles that have
that property um i found some which got
a little bit towards that in in my nks
book i'm still on a hunt for the very
simplest tiles that have that property
now into the middle of that whole story
uh polyominos are a piece of that story
and um
the uh
i actually don't know whether the
general polyamino problem
yeah the general polyamino tiling
problem must be undecidable um but i
don't uh it's not actually it's an
interesting one maybe i should look at
that one um to to try and enumerate
polyaminos for for what the what the
tiling sizes um have to be
um
so
the uh into the middle of that also came
uh roger penrose's
uh non-periodic tilings
and so the idea there was
people have thought
if you can tile with something let's say
there's a particular tile or a
particular pair of tiles people had
thought well if it's going to be able to
tile the plane then it must be possible
to make it tile periodically
and it was proved a long time ago if you
have just a single tile then if it's
going to be able to tile the plane it
must tile it in a periodic pattern there
couldn't be something where oh you have
this tile and there's a rotated version
of this tile here and there's another
one there and the pattern of of how this
tiling works is not something that is in
periodic blocks across the plane
now it had been proved that with a
single tile that would be the case if
you have two different tiles of a and b
was that going to be the case or not
and what roger penrose did in
what's that
1970-ish i think
was to show that with a particular set
of tiles
you could make something where you could
show that they did tile the plane but
you could do it by basically making this
kind of hierarchical structure this kind
of nested fractal type structure of
these tiles and that nested structure
yes it could continue forever it tiles
the plane but then you could show that
there was no purely periodic structure
with those tiles that would tile the
plane and so right now there are these
two tiles that roger pennos found
in uh that don't tell the plane there's
actually a single tile in three
dimensions that doesn't tile
periodically i think is that right i
think so um
and uh it was found more recently
but uh that's kind of the history of
this idea of tiling as i say it's still
an open question what the simplest sort
of tiling that can happen
that can be infinite but can be
non-periodic is and actually another
interesting question is can there be
tilings where it can tile but it's
neither periodic nor nested but a big
complicated messy sort of rule 30 like
thing actually found one of those
although it's by a kind of a an ugly
construction that's in the nks book but
it's not really a naturally occurring
example it's something which can tile
like the rule 30 cellular automaton but
not in a simpler way
but i've really been keen to find a
simpler version of that partly because
if you do find a simpler version you
might actually be able to make crystals
that were kind of repeatable crystals
that had a random structure
let's see maybe one or two more
questions here
um
there's a question from baker
did knowing calculus allow one to make
money in the 18th century or get a job
that's an interesting question
so kepler
in the
early 1600s
it was before calculus
kepler had invented kind of a
pre-calculus kind of idea that was
relevant for figuring out the volumes of
solids of revolution cellular revolution
is you take a shape you just turn it
around in a you know turn it around a
circle it's like a generalized cylinder
a cylinder is a sort of trivial solid
revolution but you can have more
complicated shapes that are sort of
cylindrically symmetric but have a more
complicated form so one particular more
complicated form of relevance then was
wine casks that might be you know
barrels that would bow out and then come
back and so kepler had a business
actually figuring out the volumes of
wine casks by using sort of a
pre-calculus set of ideas and that was
that was before calculus and probably in
the
oh i would guess the
16
tens perhaps i'm not sure
um
that was so that that's a place where
somebody kind of made money from
something a bit like calculus now by the
time we're in the 1700s
let's see who was making money from
calculus
um
by the 1800s
there was plenty
of
stuff where people were doing stress
analysis of actually i wonder when that
really took off
i was going to say analysis because
there was a lot of
work in building iron bridges iron ships
things like that and i don't know
exactly what mathematics was used to
figure out oh yeah actually yes yes at
those times by the 1800s for sure there
was a bunch of mathematical analysis of
of um
i'm not completely sure if it needed
calculus or if it needed more like
linear algebra to do analysis of kind of
um
uh you know of free body diagrams and
other things where you're you've got got
these members these beams and things
that are going in different directions
i know i'm kind of skipping around here
a little bit
i know um
in partial differential equations
differential equations that depend not
only on time but also in space um a
place where those were
were well those those got used a lot and
everything to do with electromagnetic
theory and that was from maxwell and
people like that it also got used the
first time that i know of where kind of
numerical methods for for
solving those were used was in world war
ii in the design of the wings of the
spitfire fighter plane um there was a
sort of numerical calculation done with
human computers um that was solving
differential equations there but coming
back to calculus in 1700s let me think
about that for a second
um there was uh
um
well
let's see but by the end of the 1800s
when people were starting but by for
example by the 1910s people were solving
equations that were for electric
circuits and things and those are
ordinary differential equations and even
nonlinear ones like the van der
oscillator equation relevant for things
like radio amplifiers and so on so that
was already pretty fancy
uh kind of differential equation stuff
by the 1910s but let me think going back
into the 1700s what were people doing
then
um
oh yes yes
very critical area how could i forget it
ballistics
um
that was a
uh a crucial early so people
uh you know you're
you're firing some big gun
and
you know big
huge shells or something and you you
fire it and it goes you know it goes a
mile well it really matters whether um
uh whether where it's going to land
because you know you're trying to you're
trying to shoot at something and if you
get it wrong if you get that
parabola-like shape wrong it's going to
land totally the wrong place
so
by certainly by the time of napoleon
um
1800-ish
um there was pretty sophisticated work
being done
on uh
on on sort of ballistics tables and
things which were calculated using
calculus
um and i think
that uh you know what what you are
trying to deal with there is you're
solving the equations you've got air
resistance you've got all kinds of other
effects that's a definitely a calculus
story now i know that even in antiquity
people like archimedes were kind of
consultants on ballistics and i assumed
that they were using some approximation
i don't think they knew about parabolic
trajectories i think that was a thing
that must have been discovered by
galileo
who discovered the fact that that the uh
the distance gone by something
accelerating in a gravitational field
like the
uniform gravitational field like the one
of the earth um goes quadratically with
with um with time that was a galileo
discovery i'm not quite sure what
archimedes did in terms of ballistics
consultant consulting although i know he
was was at least alleged to have done
that um but so ballistics definitely one
area where that would be relevant um i
would think i'm trying to think about uh
other kinds of civil engineering with
with fluid pipes with fluids in them i'm
not sure about other um
other other kinds of things there let's
see another place
where
people
okay here i thought of some others yes
here's another one it's a very important
one um
the laying of the transatlantic cable
which was um so you know people wanted
to run a telegraph cable initially
across the atlantic it was very
difficult to do that because you
basically just had to have one piece of
wire that was going to be you know a
thousand mile a few thousand miles
across the atlantic um
the uh and and you had to have it not
break
um and so it was a one of these kind of
um
uh venture capitalish you know
investment type things you know invest
in the transatlantic cable it will be
great unfortunately there's a risk that
the cable might break somewhere in the
middle of the atlantic and that happened
a couple of times
but um there was uh
william thompson later lord kelvin was
sort of brought in as the consultant to
the transatlantic cable company to try
and figure out was the cable gonna break
or not and he was definitely using
calculus to do that and i think famously
he was there with some kind of
electrometer kind of listening for the
resistivity of the cable or something as
the cable was being spooled out and sort
of saying you should go slower because i
was gonna break type thing and and he
was involved in the time when the first
successful transatlantic cable got laid
and uh i think he he was uh made
made made a good bounty from that
but um
the so that's definitely a use of
calculus and a and a place where
somebody made money using calculus now
another one that occurs to me and i'm
not quite sure how this worked was some
insurance
so uh
the um
let's see for example charles babbage
was involved in an insurance startup i
even looked at a bunch of his um uh
account books and information about his
um his involvement in what in those days
was called a joint share company um that
these days just a company with
shareholders um that uh um
uh was involved in the insurance
business
and
it was
i think so he was using actuarial tables
was it life insurance i don't know
whether that had been invented yet maybe
that was the time around which it was
invented i mean the you know the thing
that's of course mysterious about life
insurance is it's one thing to
ensure something where you say well this
ship may or may not make it across the
ocean and there's some small probability
that it won't make it across the ocean
but you you know you pay an insurance
premium and if you know and and you get
paid
paid for the ship or whatever it is in
the unlikely event that something
happens to it but
the thing that isn't obvious about life
insurance is you know uh unfortunately
at least in the current way things are
everybody dies and so therefore the
chance that you sort of the insurance
policy has to pay out is a hundred
percent and so then the question is can
you sort of arrange things so that
you're paying things in early enough
that enough interest can be generated on
that during a certain number of years
that this and that can happen and that's
a pretty mathematical problem and i'm
trying to remember whether babbage was
involved in in that already whether he
was involved in more traditional
insurance type questions but and i also
i'm not quite sure how much calculus was
involved there but certainly that was
big business um the the
insurance business was definitely a bit
big business at that time now i mean
there's plenty of things you know i
don't think the people who are making
steam engines i kind of don't think they
were using calculus i think they were
much more traditional inventors who were
just you know does it work does it not
work does the thing blow up does it not
blow up rather than let's solve a
differential equation to see what
happens
but so i think the answer is in the
1700s i would say
i i'm not immediately able to come up
with a lot of examples of where you
could use calculus well another one okay
the whole land surveying thing about
what's the area of this field and things
like that that have been a question
since babylonian times one of the
motivators for inventing geometry
actually was that question of uh you
know how big is that field how do i
compare you know i'm going to grow oats
or something on that field how much can
i grow well it depends on the area of
the field but
some of the more elaborate versions of
that definitely use calculus
although you can go surprisingly far
without using calculus and for example
in babylonian times there are sort of
high school exercises we don't know if
it's high school school exercises um
that
involved these segments of circles and
these loons and this funny thing that's
uh that's called the cow's nose
which is a kind of a thing made from
four circles um that's a funny shape and
it's a question what's the area of that
cow's nose shape and in today's world um
you know most sort of mathy uh
experienced people would say i can just
solve that with calculus but it was
solvable in babylonian times long before
calculus existed by just purely
geometrical arguments
so i think um were you to get
transported back with the knowledge of
calculus uh what could you do
um
it's uh
i'm not immediately coming up with the
the killer uh answer i mean i think
there are things um oh i should say
you know
in in the finance area the the sort of
more advanced calculus to do with
stochastic processes processes involving
some randomness that were invented well
in around 1900 some stuff was done there
and then really you know got got serious
in the 1970s um i'm not sure whether you
could have if wheeled back to the 1700s
when there were early
stock markets and things like that could
you have come in
and
made a killing using calculus i'm not
sure i don't know whether the
data quality was sufficient and whether
there was enough
kind of systematic centralized data or
whether the market was literally people
coming and saying you know
like they died i remember seeing
the late years of the
chicago board of trade you could
actually see the traders you know the
floor traders there you know a bunch of
people standing completely still and
then something would happen and a bunch
of people will be jumping up and waving
their arms and you know making hand
signals that they want to buy or sell or
whatever some pork belly futures or
whatever they were but but i think that
the early stock markets were much more
of that kind of um
um
you know i'm not sure who i'm not even
sure whether anybody was systematically
collecting the data on what was the
price so to speak if there was a single
trading pit where people were trading
whatever they were trading in the 1700s
well at some point two lit bulbs in the
netherlands that have been earlier than
that um you know was somebody sitting
there on the side recording the price
possibly yes i i don't know um but so
could that be handled quantitatively i'm
not sure all right i think we have run
out of time here
and um uh
thank you for lots of interesting
questions
and i look forward to continuing this
another time actually i'm about to do
another meeting that will be live
streamed that is a technical meeting um
piece of uh
computational language design
um coming up in a few minutes
but uh
thanks for thanks for all your questions
here